I need you
to speak before this audience. So, uh,
I guess the last week there has been
lots of talk about opinion polls.
And a funny,
surprisingly this time the exit
polls were on the dot. I almost, so,
uh, they kind of made up a
little bit for the messaging,
the big Zit to opinion polls. Well, uh,
I said I've been doing this for over about
two decades in India and I give talks
on this and,
uh,
using the talks are sometimes on the
television show as well. Uh, people say,
how can talking to 1200 waters tell you
anything about what happens to the whole
population? Uh, so, uh,
when did I picked up?
That's the typical size.
I saw all of the pools in UK in India
use really have favorable 6,000 for a
state election.
And maybe you went 20,000 for a national
election because you're a lot of
diversity, but still, uh,
then the population is,
are the number of voters is
also 700 million. And, uh,
this question still remains, how can
talking to such a small proportion,
uh, give you any insight into the
whole, uh, population. Uh, in dooly,
everybody thinks about the
proportion sample size versus
the population size and,
uh,
the least,
one of the tasks of convincing you
is that that's not important. Uh,
that's one of the tasks.
The other thing which I'll talk about,
everybody has an opinion on that,
but can open in polls conducted say a
week before the actual pool accurately
predict outcome we saw here,
uh,
the recent poll while the exit polls
got it right, even a one week earlier,
they're still seeing a comfortable
victory for conservatives.
So there are occasions when they can, and
there are occasions when they will not.
So we'll talk about that. Of course. Uh,
the whole thing is a, as a probability
statistics background. And, uh,
this slide a deliberately, I've kept it
blank is it doesn't mean no, but Magnolia,
Munich. But, uh, we'll do
it live. What background is
needed? So what I have with me,
it's just a cardboard box and what
it has our hundred slips of paper.
Okay.
I didn't tickle in all aspects and uh,
each one has a letter written on it,
either a or a B.
So you trust me on that.
And then I mixed them thoroughly and uh,
come to the audience and someone
whom I have never met before,
I asked you to pick up one. You can pick
from the top, bottom anywhere. Okay.
All right.
Can you read it out and
eat? So you, uh,
you believe that we have not
fixed this a event and uh,
one was drawn out of this box
after and that one led an eight.
Now, uh, it's just based
on this information.
If you were to make a call, uh, oh,
I forgot to say that there are 99 of them
which have one letter and exactly one
which is the outlier. Okay. So
there we are only two possibilities.
99 A's and one B or 99 B's and one eight.
Just based on this observation that it
was a one was drawn out after mixing,
etc. Etc.
And that was a a,
if you're to make a guess
between the two possibilities,
which is the likely possibility,
99, eight one B on 99 [inaudible]
99 eight.
So
a few people answered, others may have
made up their mind but didn't answer.
But uh,
if one tries to go at the background as
to what went in your mind when you pick
this all alternative, of course the
simplest explanation is just common sense.
What is there. Okay. Uh,
people who have had some statistics
background or profitability background may
compute probabilities of the two scenarios
and compare them even a sold on the
base in technology, uh, philosophy,
they would computer put a prior and
computer posterior and say that the
posterior probability of getting
it, this, this right is 99%.
So they'll go with the whichever
one turned up is your answer. Right?
So, uh, now let's say,
let's do a thought experiment.
I don't have another box,
but let's do a thought experiment
that instead of 99 one,
we had 95, five. Okay.
So one letter is 95,
another letter is five
and they are all mixed up.
And let's say I go to one person, you
drought, read it out, put it back,
we shake it up again. I come to
the second, I come to the third.
This time you will have three
observations. Okay. And we can still go.
They all could be same or we could
have two of one and one of the other.
That's why I didn't pick from one
to two, but three, no ties. Okay?
So we can talk about, go with the
majority rules with three. Okay.
And here is a slide which
convince us that uh,
the chances of in their certain loosens
chances of getting it right or again,
nine over 99%. So the first one is, uh,
all three are the same or two. Our of
the dominant one and one is the outlier.
Okay? So that's the possibilities. And
uh, so by repeating
the draws, three draws,
we have increased our
precision in a loose sense.
Precision earlier was 99%.
Now if you'd draw once
it is 95 by three draws,
we have improved the precision
to 90% and [inaudible]
uh,
does, you can still go with this
kind of a rule. Go with the majority
out of three.
Now if the gap is lesser,
we can experiment and come up with what
number is needed to reach 99% precision.
Okay. Uh, and uh,
I'll display the numbers. What
kind of a scaling up happens. Okay?
But, uh, let's do another
thought experiment.
Instead of hundreds slips, they are
a bigger box and a thousand slips.
Okay?
And once I get 95% with one
letter and 50 of 55% other ones,
a 95, you have one letter,
95% have one letter,
one 5% has the other.
So nine 50 and 50.
So 2009 50 50 is the breakup.
And this time, again,
we want to get an accuracy level of 99%.
So with hundred and 95,
five we saw it was three draws.
So how would it scale up?
Do we need three draws
your or do we need 30?
So does it scale up like multiplier or
does it scale up like square root as some
various things in statistics scale up?
What is the factor of
Scallop is the question?
The answer to this is
rather counter intuitive.
Just look at these two equations.
First one was 400 flips with 95 five
second one is 4,000 slips with nine 50 and
50.
And of course the second one,
there's just a factor of 10 in each,
uh,
factor in each term and
they would cancel out.
So, uh, with even if we are
thousand slips with nine 50,
50 distribution,
if we draw a three and go
with the majority are accuracy
level is still over 99%
precision is still owed 99%
and more in need, it scales up.
It could be anything. Instead of
thousand it would have been 100,000,
it could have been a million,
whatever.
If the distribution is 95% and 5%
we draw three go with the majority.
Precision is 99.
So this is somewhat counterintuitive
that it is the number of draws and not
total how many slips. Okay.
That besides the precision.
Uh,
so I just read an equation. We don't
have to read that, but if you have a,
if he'd died down,
the w is the support for when I'm
just saying a two party contest,
one constituency. We don't even need
to know the constitution, the size, uh,
and to candidates w percent support for
the winner and hundred minus w for the
loser. Okay. Uh,
we'd draw a odd number of
draws and accuracy of the rule.
Go with the winner in the sample is
this expression interesting thing.
This expression doesn't request population
say August size of the constituency,
number of voters in the constituency.
And
this is,
this is what is at the back of people
when the population size to somehow enter
the picture when you want precision.
That's why they say that. You know,
why so many, just the swimming out
of so many. How can you say anything?
Okay,
so
that's it.
[inaudible] now here is this a table
which I've computed that especially on the
previous slide I've just
computed explicitly, uh, far.
Uh,
so the column header is number
of draws a spelling mistake.
So column header is the number of draws.
Uh,
and the, the role harder is the
percentage of support for the winner.
So 51 is like very touch and go very
close election and 53 54 is a comfortable
election.
So when it's comfortable,
you won a 54%,
you went to how and then one,
if,
so this day equivalent of draw is going
to waters and seeking their opinion.
So, uh, if it's a comfortable
victory margin, uh,
then even work the thousand people and
getting their opinion should give you an
insight into what is likely to happen.
Uh,
99.4% accuracy exactly the same logic
as the experiment of drawing one sleep,
nothing more,
nothing less.
In fact,
we can you imagine that we draw a night
out slips with all possibilities of
thousand voters from that
constitutes put them in a box,
shake it up and take it out. We don't
have to do it as a thought experiment.
That's exactly what
it is.
And
you went 52%,
a 52 48,
five zero one five should
suffice to get good procedure.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
okay.
So another way of putting it is a
where did I'm willing to do a poll
in UK or in India where India,
that voters are at least 10
times more if not 10 times more,
uh, for a given procedure. And
I need the same sample face,
something which is very difficult
to sell it to media houses. I mean,
we do it for media houses in India and
we do it for the whole country as well as
for individual states. And they
would say half or the whole country.
We had forward budget.
Now this state is less than a
10th of the whole population.
Our budgets slashed by 10% slash two 10%.
And we have to deliver,
no, no, no, no, no. I mean,
of course they're not
going to buy this match.
So that's a tough task. But uh,
okay. Uh, one uh,
one correction in a sense that,
uh,
while in this experiment I could take,
when we are drying three,
we'll roll one slip, we put it back, shake
it up again, go to the second person,
put it back, shake and so on.
So this is v three placements.
So once you're taking it out,
you're replaced.
It in fact is you are
never going to do that.
You can't be going to the
same person thing. Oh your
name up. You're in my sample.
So you know I last you two times whether
face to face or by phone. That's stupid.
So,
uh,
in practice what is implemented is what
is called sampling without replacement.
So you take out one slip,
keep it aside,
and then go to the next
and take it out of that.
It's makes very little difference.
If anything,
he don't leave improves this table,
this accuracy of prediction.
If you live without replacement,
if anything, you don't leave Bruce.
As we can see if the tutor population
was only two five zero one and we do
without replacement,
then at 25,
two five zero and we'll get the exact
answer no matter what is the proportion.
So, uh, if the sample is a much
larger proportion of the population,
then the numbers change but only upwards.
And when the sample is like 1%
or less than these other numbers,
even in practice. So this is less than
one challenges me that uh, you know,
it does make a difference.
The population size,
it makes a difference in practice
because we do without replacement.
And even then,
uh,
when the samples collected is less than
1% of the population. This is the table.
Okay?
Okay. So the, uh,
then is how do we select this?
A 1001 or two,
five zero one.
Respondence. So what we do should
correspond to in some sense,
writing out all possible list of
that size, putting it in a big box,
shaking it up, and then drawing one. Okay.
If you don't do that, we may get, we
may not get the right answer. Okay?
So for example,
if you were to pick,
say [inaudible] people last week we
had to do something about London city.
It's a lot, all of you, but how are
the voters in London doing? Okay?
If someone said, okay, I'll just come
and stand at a Google office in pen, uh,
fix Pierre's office and first
thousand people who enter,
I just get their opinion.
Okay. Got a sample of 5,000,
uh, would that, do
you want to literally talk would tell
you that that would do, I mean, uh,
it's what would be a very,
very biased sample of a certain social
economic profile, age group and Econ,
socioeconomic profile.
Everybody has something to do with Google.
Most of them would be employed
and fuel could be visitors,
but there's something to do with Google
and that already tells you a certain
socioeconomic class.
And this would represent the opinion
of the entire city of London.
So
how do we select these thousand people?
Uh,
is the crux of this whole
methodology or technology.
And part of the problem happens
is that in colloquial terms,
people equate the word random with
arbitrary. And if you say, no,
no, we don't do well. Uh, what
is ram in our computer systems,
random access memory,
it is mistakenly call,
it should actually recall
arbitrary access memory.
That was to differentiate it from linear
access memory as in old magnetic tapes
where you could only access it linearly.
They came up with this new thing
where you could address any,
you could ask any address. So, uh,
three days actually
arbitrary access memory,
but it's got used to be
random access memory.
Now of course you'll need to call it rain.
We don't call it ran.
So this is just an example to say that
how these two things are confused in, uh,
somehow, uh, gender public's mind that,
so that's why the thing comes. It
just get some thousand people. No,
not some thousand people.
Uh,
so sometimes when I say this,
others argue with me,
what the first thousand people to enter
Google could be on one of the list.
If you make all possible lists,
this would be one of the list.
How can you say this is not random sample?
Well,
the answer to that is a random or not
is not a property of the group chosen is
the property of the
method by which you chose.
If you're telling me this
group, I can't say that. No,
this is not random because I
don't know how you have chosen it.
If you're telling me how you chosen it,
then I can make a world whether or
not it's a randomly chosen subgroup
subset. So, uh,
so especially on television, a
lot of, uh, fireworks with the,
especially from the representatives of
the parties when we are saying are going
to lose,
uh,
are based on just this approach that
either sample size and this and I ended up
saying,
okay,
so, uh, that, uh,
the point is random sampling
is a must if you do it.
Uh,
no,
so I call it,
it's a must.
If for the statistical guarantee that
the sample based prediction is accurate,
okay.
The choice of the sample should
have been chosen randomly
then,
uh,
now one could,
some shortcuts
are, one could make additional
requirements. Uh, for example, uh,
the,
uh,
if you know that there is a rural urban
divide or if you know that there's a
divide across economic strata, then, uh,
if you have a master database
where we can differentiate very,
we have data about, uh, age
groups, thought about, uh, uh,
income levels, uh, education.
So one can create subgroups and the
desire that I want to recall stratas in
statistics and for each strata,
we can pick them randomly.
The required number of,
but at the,
so we can have a smarter strategy
is to get a better representation.
But final stage,
we have to have a random
choice in a ceratin way,
uh,
done either just a random number.
Do you have a list and you generate
randomly numbers and you'll pick those.
That's easiest thing to do.
Now we don't have to make slips and
put them in a box. And so on so forth.
The, uh, implementing it, uh,
varies from place to place. Uh, what
is possible, what is not possible.
So, uh, you, you can
understand and probably,
and us also, I, it typically these days
it is done through a telephone survey.
You randomly generate
telephone numbers and, uh,
you call up people and get their opinion.
Okay.
Now, uh, the sip, this methodology
is fine. Now in the Western world,
even in the Western world,
going back a few decades,
this was not fine because the penetration
of telephones was not quite universal.
Okay?
In India, uh, is this
still not okay? Because a,
the penetration in the lower
sections of the society,
socioeconomic classes
is still rather poor.
So anything done from
telephone surveys is good.
Not going to represent
the entire population. Uh,
yeah.
Now, especially here,
people could say that,
why go through this thing of calling
up people and so on, so forth.
People are voluntarily pumping away
at a fast pace on social media.
Just pick that data and uh,
use that after all advertisers
have gone away from, uh,
doing market research in the
traditional way of sampling,
but added going with
the social media buzz.
Why not elections is a
very valid question. Uh,
the answer to that is for elections,
it won't do wildfire advertising
for mo several products.
It does work because if you're trying
to address a market and that market is
consist of people who are
active on social media, uh,
let's say somebody that advertising a
foreign company that advertising a very
good deal for wifi connectivity,
white on the move, on the mobile,
only targeting the segment.
So for them it's enough to
get the social media buzz.
But in a election scenario ago,
uh,
the day that differential usage across
socioeconomic economic classes and uh,
if one goes by social media, uh,
one is likely to make errors.
So we had three years ago in one of
the high profile elections in India,
yet looked at uh,
opinion poll based thing as
well as the social media buzz.
We got to pick the winner correctly.
You based on social media buzz and a,
the ultimate answer was
a hands down victory.
What we would have had a much bigger
victory margin if you had gone with social
media.
There was a buzz on one side.
So the uh, made me one more
time. One could do this,
but certainly even in the western world,
I don't think they can take this
as one of the boots in the model,
but the content entirely go
with the social media buzz
that will drive them away.
So,
uh,
now let me come to another
very interesting question
on the surveys can do is to
get estimate of what percentage,
what percentage of people here we're
rooting for labor and what we're waiting
waiting for the Tories. And for
the rest, the smaller parties.
But uh,
there's no magical formula which you
can input the word percentages for the
parties and output would give you how
many seats because a lot depends on how
these votes are distributed.
So,
uh, just measuring the total vote is
not good enough. On the other hand,
if for every constituency you measure
votes, then that is good enough.
But then that's the possible exercise.
Too expensive,
too time consuming and
almost not doable or,
or 600 constituencies on each one.
If you want the thousand,
that's a tough task.
Nobody would pay for that kind of a thing.
So that's not possible.
So what do we do?
On one hand,
statistically you can measure
public opinion in terms
of overall what percentage
is, but the interest for everyone, it
doesn't help me if I said no, no, no,
my work is, to me it was right, but
the seats were wrong. What can I do?
People would not listen to me if
I'm wrong. Also the other way,
if somehow I make a waiter's
cancel each other out,
our survey is wrong and my conversion is
also wrong. And eventually we get right.
If everybody public, I, I've got it right
because that is the objective function.
We are looking at fits.
Uh,
you went in the u s a it's the electoral
college votes. Not Quite the votes,
but uh,
in the system like you gate is winner
take all it a constituent filled level.
Whoever gets the largest number of votes
gets that constituency representative
is there parking in USA, the
consolidation happens at the state level.
Winner take all at the state
level. Uh, even if in the state,
the one candidate in the head from ahead
of the other with just a few hundred
votes, but they get the entire
state's electoral college votes.
That's the system in us.
And
Buddhists do do this,
namely convert votes to seats.
What we need is a kind of a
mathematical statistical model,
which would as a input taken into account
various things that we know about the
ground reality.
Uh,
the things like
how susceptible is the vote for change.
They do are the volatility of public
opinion. Now, traditionally, uh,
I had been hearing an admin tool.
I used to interact quite a bit with one
project, Clive Bain, who used to do, uh,
who are the psephologists for BBC for
a long period professor in the field
college.
And he had told me that the volatility
of public opinion in UK is very small
from one election. If you look
at from one election to the next,
how many people change their world?
That's very small. Now that scenario,
it looks like it has been changing,
uh,
this tracking the opinion polls
over the last three weeks. Uh,
three weeks ago they had measured the gap
between the Conservatives and Labor to
be, or 20%. And it came down to 2% or
1% when it came to the election time.
So the,
uh,
traditionally they used to spend a lot
of effort on what they call the marginal
seats and what was called fifth seats,
fifth for predicting where the last time
that gap was 7% or more when you can
count. This wasn't last time.
We'll win again this time.
Lot of such seats have
changed hands. So, uh,
the Martin had to take into account all
such things that one knows about the
video. Everyone is making. The prediction.
Other thing is what kind
of data is available.
One knows that socioeconomic
profile does matter when,
when for voting intention,
uh,
overall and ventured balance across that,
but at what level is the [inaudible]
profiles available. So, uh,
and you get their availability to
fairly detailed level and perhaps that
precinct level, uh, in India,
they are not available at
that level because it's
available at district level in
India,
but not at the constituency level.
So taking into account various such
reality is how susceptible is the vote for
change, what kind of other data
auxiliary data is available, uh,
taking into account all that, uh,
one built a statistical model and,
uh, then uses that to, can
work votes to seats. And
so this is where I come in actually
in our team in India where we do it,
the others do the actual
sampling and so on and so forth.
And I come into the picture for
this work to see conversion. So,
indeed, if one looks at
the last us election, uh,
everybody got it wrong, but they got
it wrong for, it was not the survey,
we'd got it wrong. It was this word to
sit conversion where they go to Trump.
Hillary Clinton did get
more votes than Trump,
and then they'd been calling that the
gap has narrowed. But there was still,
everybody was Gung Ho
about Hillary winning.
And what went wrong was what in
statistics would call their prior. So the,
like I talked about UK
in us too, they, uh,
have classified the
states into three groups,
a democratic Republican and a
swing states or marginal states.
And their entire effort was in looking
at what is happening in the marginal
stage. They had classified, okay, these
20 or this 17 going the democratic basket,
this 12 going the republican basket,
and then now let's focus on the rest.
It was this classification which went
wrong. Three of their democratic states,
I guess, Michigan,
Wisconsin, and one more, uh,
which everybody believed
cannot go out of my Democrats.
And they change sites by narrow margin.
And,
uh, if they had not changed side, Hillary
would have been precedent. So the uh,
that's the other thing.
How much weight do you give on your
prior and how much weight do you give on
your data in any statistical thing?
So they prior model all that is together
and then the data only data will not do
because you need some other information
and it's a, so it's not just a science,
it's a science and the art
you're to pick the right mix.
Okay.
So,
um,
no I I people willing to answer questions
so I'm told that increasingly
the UK, us, the answer is no.
Only about 10% of phone calls that
they make end up getting them,
getting the answers they want. Most others
just hang up as soon as they hear who,
ah, okay. Okay. I know, I
know. And they'll put it down.
Interestingly in India a while we do not
do a phone survey but actually do door
to door survey lot more expensive.
But then refusal rate is very small.
Only about eight to 9%.
If you can find the person,
people are willing to talk.
So telephone surveys much cheaper,
but then there's this huge refusal rate
and then there are lots of questions
about is there a systematic bias in being
introduced in refusal and non refuser
is it people, well, nothing
else to do, willing to answer.
And people who are otherwise have some
meaningful stuff to do are refusing to
answer. Right? So, uh,
these are questions but uh,
okay.
But even when people are willing to
answer face to face, all the more,
so they're very happy to answer.
If you ask questions about how is the
PM doing or was this policy right,
what that policy, right? Everybody
has an opinion and can do a lecture,
not just answer of yes, no, but
at the end, if you asked, okay,
so whom are you willing to vote tomorrow
or next week? Uh, answer is not going to,
why should I tell you?
Okay.
Right. Because that's considered
a private information also.
They don't know how you might
use it. So what we do is, uh,
we carry a box, something like
this, a bigger one with a slip.
It's like the simulator,
old style ballot box with a slit.
And all other questions are answered
face to face. This question,
whom are you willing to vote?
Voting intention.
We give them a slip of paper
with the names you market,
put it in a away market, bring
it back, fold it, put it in here.
People are willing to do that.
Yeah.
So there's also what is
acceptable to people.
Okay.
So it's a mix of various such things.
Understanding ground realities,
psychology of uh,
that the population,
all that goes into planning
and doing the surgery
next to the Duke.
People tell the truth.
Yeah.
And this is where there's a
lot of debate. Uh, in fact,
uh, some, uh, people who do surveys
to believe that in any case,
people either may not answer the direct
question, who are you going to vote?
Or even when the answer
we'd it meant be unreliable.
So then what they do is they impute award
based on answers to other questions.
For example, in Uk, this election
they could have had, do you think,
are you in favor of Brexit or not?
That would have been one of the questions
plus various other questions or 10
questions.
And based on that answer,
you build a model to decide whether this
respondent is likely to vote Labour or
likely to work a of eight here.
So that's one approach.
Yeah.
In India with a much larger
proportion being illiterate, uh,
this approach is unlikely to work.
Uh,
the afraid to experiment with.
We do ask questions and we do ask a
direct question and then try to correlate
and try to see if some patterns we can
find a no, it's not going to work there.
It might well be working
in the west. So, uh,
not everybody follows
this imputing methodology,
but there are serious researchers are
very searchers who do this that they asked
10 questions, 10 questions and
impute a vote based on that.
So my, my actual experience with data
is only limited to India. It's not a,
for UK,
my interaction was limited to interactions
with project life and that was also
nearly 18 years ago.
So,
uh,
another technique which is used
by some researchers is, uh,
using last food recalled to correct for
bias. So along with other questions,
you also ask, okay, how did you work last
time? They were the elections. So, uh,
and the idea is that if you see that,
uh,
let's say in your sample
you are overestimating
conservative would by 3% for the
last four, three call. That means
in spite of whatever you're trying,
you have somehow got to buy a sample
and you correct for the same by applying
this correction. So you scale down, uh,
the conservative vote by
corresponding percentages,
editing or multiplicating you can do
that and scale of the labor work. So,
uh,
this is one common technique
used by researchers and
once again in India when we
tried to do this,
we are driven far away
from the reality and again,
something to do with psychology.
So there seems to be a tendency in India
to identify with the winner. So, uh,
so, so even even when they
are very unhappy with the
government and our voting it
out, much larger proportion of
people seem to remember that the,
I don't want them now,
but five years ago I voted for them.
So we have found this
invariant of space and time.
Whoever was the winner last time seems
to have much larger recall in vote.
And uh, so we, we do
not do that. So again,
it is to do with understanding the
psychology of the nation to which one is
doing this. How do people
behave collectively? So,
so I have a favorite phrase which I use.
So electrons spinning the same way
in India is this do with vendors,
but human minds when can't stay the same.
So anything which is a physical phenomena,
uh,
one could use some model where Ted in
the West just implanted in there and it
will work. But when the phenomena
involves public interaction,
human choices being made by humans,
that could address me a starting point
and one needs to fine tune the model.
So,
Huh.
Okay. The last one, uh,
as we saw in UK itself recently,
the predictive power of a poll
done weeks ahead is not much good.
They use probably similar
methodology and exit polls.
They came out with the right numbers.
And so when there is a shifting opinion,
clearly have an opinion poll can address,
tell you what is the mood of the nation.
At the time the vote is taken,
it can not predict how it might
evolve in the last week. Uh,
so you know, uh, fluid situation
where the public opinion is,
uh, changing, uh, you can't
quite trust a bolden ahead.
There's another factor which probably
played important role in a UK in recent
one,
the
okay
bolden a week ahead or a month ahead.
Invariably of the whole population.
Now the pollsters couldn't
use their assumption, okay,
this is the overall group,
this word,
this group is unlikely to go and would
only 60% of this group will go and vote
this group, 80%. Gwen would apply those
factors and then take it together. Okay.
But that's only a guess work.
And presumably they may have done
that in UK in the pre election polls.
And uh, this time again reading
newspaper reports, I have no other input.
A younger voters turned up as much larger
proportion this time around than they
were traditionally hooting.
And that could explain that for the,
in the exit poll, they don't need to
apply such imputed percentage of votes.
They actually sample from the people
who have come to work and they therefore
cogness effect of younger people turning
up in larger proportion than ever
before. And that's how they
get got a better result.
So the predictive power of Paul
is a question mark on two counts.
One the opinion itself maybe
changing and to address,
you can be making a guesswork about
who is going to turn up to work.
You don't really know
who is going to work.
So that is what raises a question mark.
Okay.
So I guess let me stop
questions.
So you were saying that a in India
pulling through telephone doesn't work
whereas a new k. Dot. It tends to
work. But I was wondering in Uk,
I think a lot of young people are not
really using home telephones these days.
So they're using most mobile phones and
a lot of my friends that don't have time
to do you think that is representative?
Yeah, so I suppose I don't
know what they're doing,
but perhaps they are trying to somehow
factoring this into account in there
pulling method and maybe
also calling mobile numbers.
I really don't know what they're doing.
But yes,
if the old lipstick per landline numbers,
they are going to miss out
the younger group. Completely
a point. Very well taken.
Have you looked into the question of
what a public making the opinion polls
public can actually influence the
results for like tactical voting?
Yeah. Okay. Uh, so, uh, at
least based on India experience,
I do believe that there is a feedback loop
and it does impact a tactical routine.
And,
uh,
again it is to do with this what I call
the psychology of going with the winner.
So whoever the media is saying is winning
a ends up actually increasing the,
uh,
the gap typically.
So that's indirect evidence that uh,
it does have a feedback loop.
Uh, but, uh, some people ask me
then why are you associated with it?
But, uh, when others are working,
whether I knew it or not,
others are going to do it in any way.
So it's good a proper methodological
police done and released.
That's my answer to that. Yes. But it
does have a feedback loop. I don't know.
Again, west, what is it?
Belief
isn't,
so what capability does
a company like have to,
to address this problem? Because
my, my understanding is, you know,
they gather so much data on their users
and they actually have a very good
understanding of the political
preferences of, of most of them.
So as a company like Facebook actually
in a position just to kind of replace a
sample polling
maybe a water of time when they
then it becomes more universal.
But at this point, uh, I think
not because, uh, it, it really,
it can capture the opinion
of the users that it has had,
but the lower socioeconomic strata who,
even though they may be using
a mobile or be on Facebook, uh,
that group will be
completely missed. So, uh,
I think, uh, they said if your mark,
you are using this for
marketing some product, which
anyways, that segment, great,
that's big inflammation.
But for something like elections,
but African has to wait maybe
another few decades and uh,
it might become almost to new
earth then maybe are not Facebook,
something else may come up.
But social media more generally.
So, so my question is about the
sample size, a dependence on the,
on the uh,
percentages.
So as you said that it is
relatively independent sample size.
You need for the given prediction
accuracy you is independent of the total
population size.
But I'm sure that it depends a bit
more strongly on the number of choices.
Uh, so like number of, uh,
our possibilities by not
binomial but multinomial yeah,
actually no,
even that it doesn't depend what it,
it depends a lot on for
the country as a whole.
It depends on how much is
the diversity as a whole.
Right. So are you saying that for example,
if there was not just two parties,
but like in India later listen,
30 parties, right? So the choice,
the choice that you have to make is
between which of these 30 parties is going
to win.
Um,
so you're saying that the size that I
need does not actually depend on what they
started, two or 300. That
seems more counter intuitive.
But for vote to seat conversion
is a homogeneous country or is it,
so in India for example,
each state has a kind of a different
political structure and uh,
so we don't read the country as a whole.
We are predicting,
we look at each state at least
the largest state as a whole.
And so I need a reasonable sample size
at that state level because how people in
the deep South I will not
award has nothing to do with
what people in the east,
in Bengal. Uh, our thinking.
It's a complete disconnect at
least politically. And therefore,
uh,
so in that sense,
I do need to do a poll at each state,
not just getting a nationwide thing
might give me what percentage,
but it will not tell me at all
for my word proceed conversion.
So for what to see conversion,
I do need a larger,
but number of parties doesn't mess up.
There must be a defendant,
sorry. Yep, Yep,
Yep.
Because if you consider the limiting
case of the number of choices being
actually larger than the
population right now,
10 days of the pigeon hole principal
will say basically that you actually need
to hold everybody.
Uh, when I said does it
depend, you're still talking
in terms of, you know, small,
factual talking off a
million times. Yes, exactly.
To answer your question, once again,
what estimated doesn't change,
but from vote to seat,
if the direct contacts,
it's much easier when it's a
three way contest, neck to neck,
it's much more difficult.
Yeah.
How does this mortals
consider a turnout of,
uh, there are different groups
of voters since, uh, uh,
if you will pull a PR people or my,
my,
my nose Zam our bill.
Not Actual evolve.
Yeah. So, so, so that is based on
anecdotal or historical evidence?
I am. I, yeah. Yeah. So, so, so, so,
so a buy a bicycle for, uh, for example,
if you say that your most of young
people, they will vote labor, uh,
and uh, uh, and also you have the HR.
Is it when a young voters,
a actual dot don't vote? Uh, okay. Uh,
can you decrees, uh, as a, as a, as a,
as a,
as a prediction for Labor for
all right. Yeah. So that's what is done.
So you have your prior information,
believe whatever you call it,
about voting in propo propensity toward
across different socioeconomic groups
and you scale it up or down based on
that from what you get from the survey.
Yeah.
Do people ever try and do
adaptive sampling? In some sense?
You sink that you have a certain prior
belief that say people in Scotland always
vote for one party and then you
start sampling, you start sampling.
Then when you find that
actually they don't anymore.
What people have a second round
of sampling where they, uh Huh.
Yeah. I mean ideally that
would be good to do, but uh,
the time constraint comes
in because you know,
typically you would like to do it as
close as possible to the publication date
or telecast Stein and you may not
have enough time to take in all this
information and change sample sizes.
But if you do see something very
different from what you had expected,
then a second round of Paul
is indeed would add value.
So in that sense the adaptive thing is
desirable but maybe not always doable.
Uh, I was wondering, um, sorry
to follow up on that. If there's,
if you do a blended thing,
cause you're talking about like there's
a different methods of sampling and some
are more expensive than others and if you,
I don't know if you asked people on who
would they'd vote for and if that's any
different to phone poles versus like
knocking on doors versus, I don't know,
are there even more expensive approaches?
Like just do sort of blend them together?
Is that an approach?
Well I have not done so till now
because uh, the, uh, the, the,
the group which is on Twitter,
Facebook and such in India is very
small proportion of the overall thing.
So even if I want to blend that in,
I will have to give it a very tiny weight.
So that's why we have not done it.
But I guess another 10 years later,
I'm sure we'll be forced to do that too.
As it be here. They may be doing it.
Okay. Here on us because another thing
we just said is that, you know, uh,
it's also opinion makers.
So somebody is on the Facebook and
he's giving his or her opinion.
If they are able to influence,
let's say they're people who they
are come in touch with. Okay.
So these are influenced makers.
So typically these people,
so each one may be influencing
a few others choices.
So therefore that should be taken into
account is what one group is advocate.
So or time, I'm sure it will
be needed to be factored in.
Hi.
Could you talk a little bit about people's
motivations for actually wanting pull
data? I guess one obvious
example is, you know,
it's a political party or a lobbyist use
trying to actually influence the result
and therefore they're probably
interested in, you know,
what are the marginal seats,
you know,
am I very vulnerable to let's say the
youth vote and d slight fluctuations in
the youth vote in this constituency.
In which case they're not just going
to be interested in the, the final,
your final answer,
your final prediction,
but also some of the variables that went
into it and what influence they have
and where they should be focusing their
attention. I mean, Dee Dee, do you, um,
do the people who are
commissioning your poles,
are they interested in that type of
information or do they have other
motivations?
Uh, well, I'm sure that motivated
was which one fed information,
but the ones with whom I am associated
with this purely a media pool and uh,
it is guided out by a group of people
who are social scientists and they are
interested in doing it because this is
valuable data for their own research into
getting insight into why
people vote the way they did.
What were the reasons driving the vote.
So a month after they are a
television program is over,
these guys would be coming the data and
coming to more deeper answers to these
questions.
So,
but I'm sure political parties do get
a polling done on this basis by other
agencies
in cases where the, uh, the,
the opinions are very close or is
changing. Then posts seems, you know,
like you suggested earlier that, you
know, they seem to be less accurate. Uh,
apart from the solution of not doing
polling and just ignoring all the polling
data,
what,
what will you suggest kind of posters
kind of do in the future to improve?
What are we doing today that we
should be doing, you know,
a year from now when,
when we detect that there was a
mood change, you know, in the,
in the general population?
Uh, well, uh,
a lot depends on what money is
available to do the poll. Okay.
Not for the opinion poll. Okay.
So, uh, one thing could be to ask,
uh, uh, not just the sample size, but
even the questionnaire could be adapted.
Uh, you know, if you, you know,
we are tracking the same people and if
you today say something different from
what you said one week ago,
then the questions I should
ask you should be more probing.
You know what happened during this week.
So I will,
everybody based on newspaper
reports are media reports,
would know five big events which happen.
So then we should drill down into each
of these influence you or change. Okay.
Things like that can be done, but
it requires a lot more money. So,
uh, let me, uh,
maybe one or two more comments then
the other than media these days.
The other interesting opinion
polls is the financial markets.
So if you read the evening tabloids
the day before the polling,
they were giving various scenarios
and how will the market react?
And so the market players are
very much interested in, uh,
because finally the election
outcome does it impact the market.
So they are very much interested
in anticipating this. And
uh, in India has seen,
uh, financial, uh, groups, uh,
commissioning survey are trying to get
us to come and talk to them and get
bigger, better insight into
what is happening. I'm sure
it is happening here too.
So the financial, so more
time, more than the media,
it could be the financial markets,
which would be engaging pollsters perhaps.
I have a bit of a question about the,
um,
the use of opinion polls to influence the
outcome of elections and whether there
has been any examples of political
parties trying to introduce biased opinion
polls or introduce bias into the sampling
methods or anything like that to try
and,
um,
sort of shift the election
in their direction and if
that sort of thing does or
could happen, what they might might
be to, uh, to protect against that.
Yeah, so, uh,
in India and I would want to
have [inaudible] but there
is enough circumstantial
evidence that this kind of
things have happened. And, uh,
all I can say is that, you know, we had,
we not been approached and we were with
the media house for whom we were doing
the polls. We had a very
clear, uh, understanding, uh,
contract that a, they cannot
influence what we will say
after commissioning. Paul.
They can refuse to put us on here.
That is their prerogative.
But if they put us on air,
we will only say what our surveys
say even if it is wrong. But, uh,
there are in fact in India two years ago,
they were before this a high profile
election, there was a sting operation.
Somebody posing as a, an acting on behalf
of certain political parties went act,
talk to 10 different agencies and uh,
uh,
trying to indirectly say that,
you know, what, if you know,
we want to fine tune your findings in a
certain way and seven out of the 10 did
indicate that the EIT may cost.
But it is possible we can
debate and discuss such things.
They were caught on camera.
So
yeah,
in the, uh, in the u s the,
there is a newspaper who did a completely
different approach. They had like, uh,
a group of 100 or 160
people of which they,
the opinion and based on
that data inferences on,
on what they believed the election
results would be. What is your opinion on,
on such an approach
instead of random sampling?
Uh,
I would say, uh, I won't go
with that. I mean, they, uh,
they may be right on occasions, but, uh,
there's no reason why these hundred
people alone would determine what is the
entire mood in the nation, right? I
mean, um, and we changed that hundred,
2000 doesn't Jay, of course, we know
that e television rating system,
PRP system is everywhere based
on such an approach. Okay.
But it's debated, uh, there, the
question is what else can they do?
Okay.
But in our opinion, Paul, having
a fixed sample could track, uh,
I think would have a limited value,
but when we'll have to see how
their predictions evolve over time.
Ultimately,
that's the only measure overall thing.
Any more questions?
If there are no questions anymore,
then please thank our guest.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.